[موسيقى]
امتطاء الافعوانيات ركوب قطارات الموت
ودخول المنازل المسكونه وغيرها من وسائل
الترفيه تقودك الى مكان واحد هو مدن
الالعاب لكن هذه العوالم التي تجلب
لزائرها الفرح وترفعه هرمون الادرينالين
لم تنشا الا نتيجه ابداعات بشريه عبر
الزمن فكيف حدث ذلك
بدات فكره مدن الالعاب من سعي الشعوب
لتوفير فرص للترفيه ففي روما وجدت الالعاب
القتاليه فيما جذبت رياضه تشبه كره القدم
شعب المايا للملاعب الكبيره قبل ان تصبح
مناسبات الحصاد والاعياد الدينيه موسما
لعروض الترفيه خلال العصور الوسطى في
اوروبا وغيرها ضمت هذه العروض فعاليات
بسيطه
كالرمايه والفروسيه وكانت هناك العاب
بسيطه كان يجلس الشخص التي تدور حول عمود
كانت هذه الفعاليات تقام بشكل مؤقت حتى
افتتحت الدنمارك متنزهه
او باكن في عام
1583 حيث ضم وسائل ترفيه كرنفاليه كان هذا
باكوره مدن الالعاب التي بدات تنتشر في
اوروبا والعالم خصوصا خلال القرن الثامن
عشر حيث مثلت اماكن للتنزه والاستمتاع
بالموسيقى الحيه والالعاب البهلوانيه
والمسرحيه والالعاب الناريه كما كان
المهندسون المعماريون والفنانون يعرضون
ابداعاتهم الفنيه فيها
شهد القرن التاسع عشر تطوير تقنيات جديده
للركوب الميكانيكي ففي عام
1861 وجدت سكه ركوب دائريه تعمل بالبخار
بانجلترا كما ظهرت في عام
1867 لعبه الخيول الخشبيه الدائره وجاءت
بعدها العاب اخرى كالقطارات والاراجيح
وحتى المنازل المسكونه خلال اواخر القرن
التاسع عشر اسهمت انظمه سيارات الترول
الامريكيه التي تعمل بالكهرباء في تطوير
مدن العاب صغيره لركوب العربات خارج ساعات
التنقل والعطلات مع حلول الكساد وظهور
التلفاز مطلع القرن الماضي طولت مدن
الالعاب من تجهيزاتها لجذب الناس فعملت
مدينه كينز في ولايه اوهايو عام
1972 على بناء اول
بامضاء المهندس جون الين تحت اسمي ذا ريسر
كانت سرعتها 53 ميلا في الساعه مع ارتفاع
نحو
88 قدما وكانت لها مسارات يتسابق فيها
قطارا مكان جاذبا للزوار فواصلت العمل
لتقدم في عام
1979 سفينه الوحش بيست وهي اطول سفينه
خشبيه في العالم
واسرعها مع حلول منتصف القرن العشرين عاشت
مدن الالعاب عصرا ذهبيا وانتشرت في كل ركن
بالعالم وهو الوقت الذي افتتحت فيه مدينه
ديزني لاند لتضم مجموعه مبتكره وساحره من
الالعاب وعروض الفرح والترفيه فباتت مكانا
جاذبا للزوار من جميع انحاء العالم بل
ووصفت بانها اسعد مكان على وجه الارض مع
تقدم التكنولوجيا والتطور الرقمي ليس هناك
الا الانتظار ليشهد العالم ابداعات غير
محدوده في مدن الالعاب